hello and welcome to engage and
translate
text and audio chat in over a hundred
languages
i'm sarah weldon product manager for
google cloud translation services which
include
apis for pre-trained and customizable
machine translation models
and a new beta api for supporting
streaming audio translation
more on that later i'll be joined later
in this talk with dale markowitz
applied ai engineer at google cloud and
she'll bring some of the features
that we are discussing to life in a
couple of demos
today's companies their employees and
their customers are truly global
and every day they're also more digital
keeping pace with the exchange of
information
in multiple languages at scale is a
grind challenge
especially so when more work is moving
to virtual
so companies are turning to machine
learning to augment their workloads
and make content more accessible faster
than would be possible without
automation luckily advances in machine
translation continue to drive up quality
and new features on our products give
customers more control
over how their content is translated
more on that later
let's take a quick look at where we
started
pre-2016 the world is relying on
statistical machine translation
as an example for this we take a set
paragraph
from a japanese language and we
translate it into
into english for readability so in this
case this translates as kilimanjaro is
nineteen thousand seven hundred and ten
feet
of the mountain covered with snow and it
is said to be the highest mountain in
africa
it's a little awkward in how it's
written as well as there's some words
missing if you're a fluent reader
but if we move fast forward to today um
we've done a lot of work to improve
machine translation using machine
learning
and so we introduced google introduced a
neuro machine translation
after 2016 and into 2017 and under
that new model this same translation
would come through as
kilimanjaro is a mountain of 19 710 feet
covered with snow and is said to be the
highest mountain in africa
it's a much more fluent translation it
doesn't feel awkward
and it's a good number of words
but we keep improving even beyond this
in summary
the last major jump in quality we saw
was in 2016 to 2017 but we've
continuously
improved over the years as well and in
the most recent year
with you see with this graph in green we
saw an
increased jump over multiple languages
through a number of different technology
investments driven by our research teams
and it averaged a five point blue score
jump over
a hundred plus languages and this
improvement
is comparable to the gain observed years
ago when translating from statistical
to neural machine translation as they
spoke about a few minutes ago
so our products include translation api
basic
translation api advanced and automl
translation
and then the new one that i was talking
about a little bit later for translation
api basic
the implementations on it are really
intended for simple use cases
it's intended for user generated content
where you're not trying to control a lot
of the specific translations
so we wanted to make it very simple to
use
and so translation api basic does do
important things still with language
detection
and it also continues to use the
advancements of the new machine learning
models as we release them and develop
new languages
but you can use translation api basic
for chat scenarios and user generated
content because it's easy to integrate
with
and you're not trying to change the
translations after the fact for a number
of these cases
but um in this user generated content it
still is
really easy to use and will enable you
to easily integrate with many languages
at a very simple platform as an example
case
i'll tell you a little bit about a
gaming scenario where we had one of our
our customers in this case elix which
publishes games
in mobile mobile gaming chat and their
gamers
are international and so when the gamers
are wanting to talk to each other and
collaborate in order to achieve certain
goals
or to just chat online they sometimes
need to be able to cross between
multiple languages and so by integrating
with the translation api basic elix is
able to
improve the engagement experience for
their end users
and be able to improve the overall
gaming experience just by connecting in
with our apis
but this isn't just specific to gaming
or to tech it's actually really useful
for government scenarios as well
so let's talk about another customer
scenario this time public sector
within the us many languages are spoken
and governments are required to make
information accessible to their
constituents
let's look at how machine translation
can help with this scenario
so i'll turn it over to dale
thanks sarah um i'm dale i'm an applied
ai engineer here at google
and i'm talking to you from austin texas
texas is a really interesting state
because it's actually the second most
multilingual state in the us
after california and something like one
in three people don't actually
speak english as their first language in
their homes so it's really important
especially in times like these
uh that the city is able to to
communicate with constituents in their
own languages
so i recently had heard about this
project it was actually done by the
state of hawaii
where they used the google translate api
to automatically translate a bunch of
legislative documents so that all of
their constituents could
understand the documents so i kind of
wondered could i do the same thing for
austin
so i decided i would go to the austin
website and i found a bunch of different
questions that people ask you know
where do i take out my garbage or how do
i report a leaking fire hydrant
and i decided to build a chatbot that
understands questions and then gives the
city's answers
but i use the translation api to be able
to detect what language people are
asking in
and then respond in their own language
so let's take a look
this is a chat app that i built to
answer questions about the city of
austin it recognizes lots of languages
so for example if i ask how to check if
i'm registered to vote in spanish
it will detect my language and use the
translation api to respond in the same
language
the translation api supports over 100
different languages
and lots of different character sets so
you can write your app code once and
have it work
all over the world
so the demo that i just showed you it
was working with a chat bot that had
some preset answers but actually the
architecture works exactly the same for
any sort of chat like for example if i
was building a chat app to chat with
sarah and we want to use two different
languages
so let me walk you through how it works
so the first thing you might have
noticed is that you didn't actually have
to specify what language you wanted to
use chat in
that's because the translation api if
you give it enough text can actually
tell what the language is
so the text gets sent from the chat
client to a server the translation api
detects the language
and then it translates the sentence to
english because my chatbot only
understands english
then once the chatbot replies we use the
translation api again
to translate back to the the sender's
language and send the response back to
the chat app
and that's how you can build a
translation chat app now this worked
really well for
the majority of the taste the cases that
i tested but there were some where it
didn't do that well in terms of
translation quality
and those are the cases where there was
some really specific like austin
terminology like the name of our metro
system
or some really specific words for things
in austin
so i'm going to hand it back to sarah
and she'll tell you how you can improve
quality for domain specific cases
thanks dale that was great now let's
talk about what we can do to modify
content to better represent different
possible translations within a language
depending on the industry context or
location
so in this scenario i'm thinking of
public sector again
and it's a pretty common thing to want
to be able to provide comments
to a public agency in this case let's
say the attorney general
now is if you're talking to um to users
that are in spanish
they're speaking spanish there's a
pretty common translation
for attorney general which is fiscal
henrol
um so in this case our machine
translation would automatically select
this for the
for the translated response but there
are other countries
uh say in latin america they might have
a different version of what they call
their attorney general's office in this
case ministerio publico fiscal
um but even in california we actually
have
they actually have a predescribed
glossary and if you look at that they
refer to their attorney general's office
in spanish as
so what if you could customize your
translations to your domain
if translation api advanced you can
actually do this
and if you have a terminology base which
a lot of public organizations do
and companies do as well then you can
use this as your starting point
with an easy integration with
translation api advanced
because you have your english terms and
your terms in other target languages
if you just create this into a csv file
and import it into your
google cloud project then you can use
this with future cases for machine
translation
just by referencing your glossary in
your translation api call
and then when you get the response back
it'll actually preserve your preferred
term
over what the pre machine translation
might have otherwise predicted
and translation api advanced also has
other features that can help
with both scaling your implementation as
well as more advanced customization
capabilities
with our custom machine translation
models all of it can be done through one
api
integrated with your gcp project
but let's say you have even more than
just terminology and you want to go
further you're a company or an
organization that has a lot of past
human translations
and you want to be able to use those
translations to improve the machine
translation prediction
for what a translation would likely be
for your content
your context or your industry
so in that case um it's really important
to understand
conceptually that google has both
pre-trained models which is what you
typically use with machine translation
api
advanced or our translation api basic
um and these are pre-trained models that
we've created using a lot of training
data
but if you have your own training data
you can actually use those as a starting
point and then build and improve on them
with a custom training on automl
translation
so by taking your past human
translations bringing that to our
platform and running trainings on it
then you're improving the statistical
and mission
like mathematical likelihood that our
model is going to provide back to you a
translation
that's tuned to your context and to your
industry
so it does this through transfer
learning and it has an entire platform
where you can go and learn and manage
more of these
models um to integrate it with with more
advancements in your platform
but now let's go back to our chat
scenario our chat
app uses the right language
but it doesn't speak it's actually just
using text translation
so if since users both write and talk
there are scenarios where we might want
to have audio as well as
text translation supported for our our
use cases
so can we translate speech in real time
organizations are seeing value in
delivering their products and content
globally
and it's not just in text it's in video
it's an audio
it's in calls and so for these scenarios
you want to be able to have an easier
way to implement
translations for those use cases and
it's applicable in media entertainment
it's applicable in technology and it's
applicable for service providers that
might be trying to support customer
support cases
but what's so complicated about
translating non-text data with audio and
video
we have our speech apis and our video
apis that allow for interacting with
those types of content
and we have translations so we can just
integrate between
all three of them in order to be able to
get an outcome
but it's kind of hard to do and it comes
with other challenges that are
nearly impossible to solve on the
developer client side so we're looking
at how to solve that
on the cloud side for one thing
latency can be a lot higher if you're
integrating across multiple apis
especially if one is set up for
streaming and the other one is set up
for more synchronous cases where it's
waiting for
the the content to finish before it
starts to figuring out what a
translation would be
additionally you have to do multiple api
calls
so that can be complexity for developers
to work with especially if you're trying
to figure out how to improve accuracy
etc
across these two different apis and then
you're also
dealing with a streaming client which
creates some complexities with
integrations and usability
and it's it's a challenge in itself
so media translation api simplifies this
process
it supports directly audio files or
microphone input
say through a mobile phone or through
your browser and
it also accepts that content directly so
you're not having to run through
a speech model first and then a
translation model in order to get a
translation back
you can go directly to translation media
translation api with your audio
and you'll get back a text translation
in the language which you've set as your
target language for
translation outcome
in addition to abstracting away the
frictions of multiple api calls
we have some other features that overall
improve the experience
so automatic punctuation detection as
well as
using enhanced models for video or
telephony
use cases allows you to be able to
make the most to get the best quality
optimized for your audio translation
outputs
and then we also have language support
because it's a translation model
so we support french german italian
hindi portuguese russian spanish
english and others for you to be able to
translate multiple languages for your
user base
so with that i'll take it back to dale
and so we can see
the translate media translation api in
action
thank you sarah so as developer i can
confirm that it is tricky to do anything
in real time especially real-time
translation
but the media translation api makes this
a lot easier which is great because
there are so many times i want to do
real-time translation like
imagine if i'm doing a live stream and i
want users all around the world to
understand it
or maybe i'm giving a talk in person and
i want different audience members with
different languages to get what i'm
saying
so i'm going to show you something that
i built with the media translation api
and a raspberry pi and a mini projector
and
let's take a look hi my name is dale
i'm using the media translation api
and a raspberry pi to translate what i'm
saying in real time
so that is what i'm bringing to my talk
next time i give a talk somewhere that
speaks a different language
and with that i'll give it back to sarah
thanks dale
i wanted to close with some thoughts
from one of our translation customers
for media translation api
when they integrated with our media
translation api they were able to see
gains in latency as well as the overall
quality performance
um and so they're able to provide
real-time streaming translation
for video chat oneplus is a phone
provider
and they've created a beta application
that allows for their customers to be
able to opt in
and see able to see the translations
from the person that they're speaking in
a different language while they're still
engaged with them in
in video chat and so with this we're
able to demonstrate
how text translation audio translation
can work seamlessly together
to create a better end user experience
to close i wanted to point you to our
documentation
on our cloud website where you can get
more information on
automl translation translation api
advanced
and our new media translation api please
check them out
thanks for joining us
you